joyfully stuffed with Easter eggs or
just overstuffed in general the Super
Mario Brothers movie is causing some
surprising reactions among fans in
keeping up the recent trend of bringing
video games to the cinema the Super
Mario Brothers movie has finally made it
to the Silver Screen it's had quite an
uphill battle to fight but it seemed to
have all the tools necessary to succeed
from an animation style that's true to
the Nintendo Source material and a stout
cast including the likes of Chris Pratt
Jack Black and Anya Taylor joy to name a
few what could go wrong so far the
animated feature isn't garnering the
most glowing reactions from critics
sitting at a 53 Russian critic score on
Rotten Tomatoes at the time of this
video critics who have had the chance to
see its early complain of its basic
story disappointing performances and
overall unremarkable presentation of
course at the end of the day critics are
just a very small portion of a movie's
entire viewing audience case in point of
setting up 53 critic score on Rotten
Tomatoes is a glowing 96 send audience
rating ooh fresh meat for the grinder so
what do some of the first fans who have
gone to see the Super Mario Brothers
movie at the local theater think of it
our 30 thoughts on the Super Mario
Brothers movie made their way to Twitter
it became abundantly clear that if
you're a fan of the source material odds
are you'll be more than happy with this
animated take one person wrote the Super
Mario Brothers movie is curated exactly
for its intended audience kids it's like
watching the video game come to life the
same person added that while the plus
and character developments are minimal
those drawbacks too little to harm the
film's fun Factor another fan noted that
they also quite liked the movie though
while they're excited for Mario's future
at the cinema they do feel the flick
doesn't measure up to the Sonic the
Hedgehog duology keeping the comparisons
going another thumb boldly put the Super
Mario Brothers movie in contention for
best movie of the year was John Wick
chapter 4. plenty of fans give it High
Praise going as far as calling critics
wrong for their negative assessments of
it one person was particularly Blown
Away by how much the film managed to
effectively pack in tweeting they didn't
Miss A Beat from your childhood to
everything Mario even Mario Kart to
Luigi's Mansion all of it somehow
coordinated everything without seeming
rushed slash corny even though there are
numerous supporters of the Super Mario
Brothers movie expressing their love for
the feature on social media other
Twitter users have made it clear that
they're not fans of the final film for
several reasons for one audience member
the Super Mario Brothers movie only has
a couple of redeeming qualities chiefly
the visuals and Charlie Day's Luigi
performance otherwise they find the film
Hollow rushed and overstuffed with
cameos that serve only to keep audiences
occupied with Nostalgia how
they're not alone another fan was also
disappointed with the feature noting
that something about it was off that
made it hard for them to enjoy it I just
found the fan service overwhelming the
story rushed and the pacing rough
concluding fun movie but overall a 6 out
of 10. the fan service was apparently a
common sticking point with yet another
user commenting that the movie focuses
more on throwing out Nintendo Easter
eggs than crafting a solid story of
course exclusively listening to fans and
critics has no way to form an opinion on
a piece of entertainment if you want to
see for yourself how the Super Mario
Brothers movie turned out it's currently
playing in theaters
foreign